I've always wanted to be in the Guinness Book of World Records since I was a small child.
In fact, I made a list of ten things I had to do before I die...
...and this was one of the things I had to do.
The greatest thing about Guinness World Records is the way they celebrate people's uniqueness,...
...and then everybody has one special freak skill and this just happens to be mine.
I've been doing balloons since I was a very small child.
I received a small kit. It was a balloon modeling kit.
My family, I think they're still hoping it's a phase but it's long past that.
I have been doing it for such a long time and it's wonderful.
The reason people are constantly trying to break records is they wanna be able to feel special.
Every single person in this world wants to feel special.
They wanna feel like they have something that they can do,...
...a special skill, something that they can do better than anybody else in the world.
And that is what Guinness World Records celebrates,....
...everybody's uniqueness.
I can't think of a better gift than to be in the book myself.